bonsoir
cette nouvelle session d'information
voilà tout d'abord ce que l'on peut
retenir dans ce journal du vendredi 27
février
les trains sont ils trop cher c'est la
question que nous posons dans quelques
instants notre invité philippe le règle
c'est que choisir alors qu'un rapport de
l'association pointe du doigt les tarifs
et la satisfaction des usagers
les dates des prochaines élections
municipales à voisins le bretonneux ne
sont pas encore connues mais c'est une
guerre des droites que vont devoir
arbitrer les électeurs actuels et
anciens maires sont à couteaux tirés
et puis une bonne nouvelle pour les 350
licenciés du comité handisport des
yvelines
il bénéficie depuis ce vendredi d'un
nouveau véhicule important pour leur
permettre de pratiquer leur activité et
donc on débute avec cette bonne nouvelle
pour les pratiquants handisport ce
vendredi a symboliquement une voiture
adaptée a été remise à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie qui s'est déroulée au siège du
comité handisport des yvelines un
renault trafic adapté aux personnes en
situation de handicap
les vingt-huit mille euros nécessaires
pour l'achat ont été débloqués par le
conseil général
on écoute daniel blanchet c'est le
président du comité handisport des
yvelines nous on est on est bien bien
content de ce coup de main parce que ça
nous permet de nous développer encore
plus en fait 1 et 2 notre but c'est
d'amener des gens à pratiquer un donc il
faut savoir qu'on est 350 licenciés dans
le département des yvelines donc on on
sait aussi qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
plus de la faim dans les capés qui
pratiquent pas donc c'est aussi pour
notre mission se développer des
activités
et justement pour développer les
activités le véhicule va être utilisé
pour la première fois dans deux semaines
pour un stage de ski en fauteuil dans la
station de la plagne et d'ici là à la
voiture sera utilisé pour des actions de
sensibilisation dans les collèges on
change de sujet nos très chers train
c'est ainsi que pourrait se résumer l'
enquête menée sur tout le territoire par
l'association ufc que choisir pour en
parler avec nous ce soir son
représentant départemental fille
pleurait bonsoir l'ufc que choisir a
publié le 18 février deux enquêtes sur
la sncf l'une portait sur un conte
peyras comparatif des tarifs de tgv sur
80 liaison directe et l'autre sur la
satisfaction client pour tout type de
trains confondus on va donc d'abord
parler des des tarifs qu'est ce qu'on
peut retenir sur cette enquête c'est que
les tarifs sont trop chers ou alors ils
sont compliqués à comprendre deux choses
la première c'est que il y ait une
augmentation de tarif de 2,6 pour cent
au 1er janvier alors que l'inflation est
seulement de +0 cas donc une
augmentation supérieure à l'inflation
que les tarifs sont compliqués à
comprendre je pense y revenir et puis
également donc il ya des difficultés de
compréhension
alors justement moi je trouve que les
tags c'est compliqué parce qu'on va sur
le site sncf on n'a jamais le même tarif
pour un même allé au 1 1 aller retour
comment commence on définit justement
ces tarifs est ce qu'il ya des critères
déjà il ya plusieurs critères
auparavant c'était une tarification au
kilomètre et puis depuis quelques années
la sncf a abandonné ce principe de
tarification est donc maintenant établi
sa faim sa tarification en fonction de
plusieurs critères la date de
réservation
le taux de remplissage le voyage et puis
également la période de haut cours du
week-end le trajet sera effectué donc ça
veut dire qu'en gros il faut s'y prendre
très tôt et il faut voyager une période
de personnes le voyage c'est à dire
éventuellement on sait surtout pas le
week-end évidemment jamais le dimanche
soir etc
non moi je dois aussi prendre plus tôt
c'est vrai puisque s'est aperçu à
travers l' enquête c'est que par exemple
les scripts des billets prem's
ils ne sont pas sur toutes les liaisons
sur tous les voyages donc déjà première
interrogation il ya une explication de
la sncf là dessus non pas vraiment
quand ils font des pays des billets pas
cher sur certaines destinations et alors
le dit avant effectivement le billet
était calculée en fonction du kilomètre
par contre qui semblait logique on va
loin pas cher et bien pas vraiment en
fait si on fait le comparatif entre
paris et reims où un paris marseille au
kilomètre on n'arrive pas mais voilà on
s'aperçoit que plus c'est court plus
c'est cher c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit là
et donc oui par exemple paris paris
reims donc tous les trajets de moins de
moins d'une heure c'est environ 40 88 45
minutes là c'est pas très cool très cher
un plus de plus de 20 centimes en
moyenne sur un trajet de deux mois d'une
heure ces 20 centimes le kilomètre de
mes parents je ressasse et 31 de mémoire
ses 31 centimes le kilomètre par contre
dax pau par exemple des liaisons comme
ça c'est c'est beaucoup moins cher et
vous vous demandez au sein l'association
demandé à la sncf de rectifier ses
tarifs d'être un peu plus clair on
demande d'être plus cohérent et d'être
plus simple pour les peaux les usagers
et la réponse qui vous est faite par
rosberg qui est fait et c'est qu'ils
sont dans une démarche commerciale et
qu'ils ont des investissements très
lourds ce que ce qui est vrai et donc
que c'est pas facile
certainement de simplifier bien qu'il y
ait des engagements on va parler dans
quelques instants de la satisfaction des
usagers l'on va voir que la sncf a pas
forcément la cote auprès des usagers
mais on va s'arrêter un instant avant de
poursuivre cette enquête sur la vie est
des saint quentinois sur le coût des
transports en région parisienne en tout
cas ce coup elle n'est pas vécue comme
exorbitants oui un peu mais à ce qui
paraît ça va changer ça va changer
bon
on réduire ça à 110 euros par tous en
tout les uns donc ça va ah oui est ce
qu'en fait je vais en cours et des fois
je suis en stage et c'est pas forcément
évident parce que je trouve que le choix
il n'est pas énorme
soit on prend à la semaine soit on prend
mois et enfin je ne trouve pas avantagés
et je trouve sa voix est vraiment trop
cher même par rapport aux zones et tout
ça je trouve que je gaspille énormément
d'argent dedans en peluche et étudiantes
du nom parce qu'on a les deux mains
tarifs donc donc ça va
moi personnellement non parce que
j'utilise que des zones donc
personnellement ça me gêne pas de désir
est que le dézonage que j'ai entendu
qu'ils a dépassé au dézonage à 70 euros
c'est avantageux est désavantageux pour
certains on m'a dit que c'était
excessivement cher quand même sur les
drones ça c'est vrai que j'en entends
parler
voilà des avis partagés on va maintenant
parler de la satisfaction des usagers
selon toujours l'enquète ufc que choisir
54% des personnes interrogées se
déclarent satisfaits c'est quatre points
de moins qu'en 2002 et vous me disais
pour un service public c'est pas bon du
tout oui non parce que généralement pour
des services publics équivalent on
considère qu'une bonne qualité de
service autour de 75% en envoyer que
l'écart très important entre les entre
les deux
quels sont les points un peu d'accrocher
en tout cas qu'est ce qui ne plaît pas
le plus c'est quoi c'est la ponctualité
alors tout dépends d'eads et des
liaisons sont généralement la qualité de
service est mieux perçue pour les tgv
par exemple et le lait moins bien perçu
ces 2 transilien
donc tout ce qui est région ile de
france les avis sont très très négatif
assez négatif par rapport à quoi par
rapport à leurs combattants
actualité parole de l'autorité et or
hauteur et bien sûr alors et d'un autre
côté les gens ne sont pas contents la
ponctualité et la sncf est arrivé avec
ces chiffres parce qu'ils ont des
statistiques et disent que pour eux 90%
des trains sont à l'heure alors comment
vous expliquer qu'à la fois sncf 10 90%
notera sont à l'heure ce que ton pas mal
aux côtes et les usagers ne sont pas du
tout contents ils estiment qu'ils sont
perception la réalité qui est différente
d'un côté comme ça c'est vrai que ce
n'était autre perception mais malgré
tout il ya des réalités c'est à dire que
ce qui est notamment reproché à la sncf
2 pour les retards c'est un défaut
d'information
c'est généralement les gens n'ont pas le
temps d'anticiper et de s'organiser et
puis un problème
de remboursement aussi en cas de trop
tard et vous pensez de la semaine
s'appelle vraiment une mauvaise image à
ce point là ils ont une mauvaise image
cyril saux faut bien voir ils sont en
situation de quasi-monopole sur beaucoup
de liaison donc il ya quand même des
choses qui le syndicat de cheminots vous
dirait de moins en moins faire une sorte
de fait semble de fait même si la loi ou
les ouvre la possibilité sur la
concurrence oui donc oui je me disais
que la perception c'est celle ci c'est à
dire qu' il ya des désaxés de
mécontentement et puis après qui retombe
effectivement poser la première question
comment vous avez réalisé 24 été rédigé
à partir d'un questionnaire qui était
inséré dans la revue mensuelle de l'ufc
que choisir de novembre 2014 et donc
nous avons eu plus de 7000 répondu c'est
déjà un échantillon important donc sur
l'ensemble du territoire français dont
vous êtes content oui de ce nombre de
succès
avant de terminer cette 33ème faire
réagir aussi fictif l'argent profite sur
sur deux points d'abord sur le système
d'étiquetage alimentaire je voulais
montrer le dernier numéro 1 tout chaud
celui du mois de mars
justement il est question des qualités
nutritionnelles vous en pensez quoi de
ce système d'étiquetage alimentaire qui
va être simplifiée pour mieux connaître
la la valeur mieux comprendre en tout
cas la valeur nutritionnelle des
aliments avec des petites taches de
couleurs qui vont du vert au rouge est
ce que c'est c'est plutôt positif vu
comme ça ça a l'air très positif oui
c'est la rive mais là aussi ciblé il
faut que le
l'information soit soit concise et clair
je sais le principe trop trop
d'information tué l'information et c'est
vrai que un produit alimentaire germans
les surfaces pour mettre les inventions
sont réduites relativement réduits des
puits et des procédés de marketing
publicité vous faut mettre de la couleur
de ces choses a donc on peut pas tout
mettre
donc il faut faire des choix donc je
sais pas vous avez pu voir que par
exemple le sénat avait voté une loi
récemment précisant que la date
d'utilisation optimale allaient être
abandonnés à mario pouliot qui a marqué
de préférence à monter peut-être ça va
ça va disparaître
donc peut-être dur un peu plus de plates
ou à d'autres informations sur la
qualité énergétique sur la qualité par
exemple au niveau de la santé mais au
niveau de la qualité nutritionnelle
c'est important d'avoir son vélo
couleurs comme oui je pense que c'est
important d'entendre de la santé si on
veut lutter par contre l'obésité par
exemple c'est important de voir ce type
d'information bien sûr autre question
parce que ces sujets du moment et fameux
détecteur de fumée nous qu'on nous dit
que 8 mars ça va être obligatoire
d'avoir ces fameux détecteur de fumée
chez soi alors d'abord est ce que c'est
vrai c'est au 8 mars à ce cas une
prolongation
je veux dire ne vous laissez pas enfumer
de limites oui mais maintenant ils des
tolérances qui pour reporter sa de
l'année 2015 et puisqu'il faut savoir si
les pas de sanction en fait si vous
n'avez pas et ne seraient pas punis
ce communiqué ce cas une sanction de la
part des assureurs si on a un incendie
dans sa maison qu'on n'a pas le
détecteur de fumée mais différent je
peux dire on vous rembourse pas non non
non si vous avez aimé 110 et des dégâts
matériels ça ça marchera toujours 5 à 2
de blessures ou de décès dans ce faire
la queue à que la science mais les
assurances
à ma connaissance on encore contacté
personne à ce sujet donc je pense
qu'elles vont se réveiller on va voir ce
réveillon bon moment sur le coup c'est
qu'on peut devenir un consommateur pour
acheter un bon détecteur en tout cas on
n'a pas donné une marque mais faut faire
attention à quoi sur l'emballage parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens il
faut il faut cliquer tryphon qu'il y ait
la norme nf sas et c'est ce que l'on
préconise très fortement au niveau de
l'ufc que choisir
et donc il faut aussi vérifier certaines
choses par exemple si vous avez un
détecteur avec une garantie 5 ans par
exemple et qui a et il faut vérifier la
pile
il faut que ça soit une pile au lithium
si c'est une petite pile ordinaire
tiendra pas 5 à envoyer donc déjà
méfiance de ce coffret cd question des
questions de bon sens sera pas forcément
aller au plafond pour les changer tous
les ans quoi merci beaucoup pour tout
vos conseils merci d'être venu sur le
journal on va continuer cette édition
avec une page politique
le tribunal administratif n'avait pas
voulu annuler les élections le conseil
d'état saisi en deuxième instance à lui
trancher ce mercredi à 25 février il
faudra bien revoter à voisins le
bretonneux des nouvelles élections qui
devraient avoir lieu dans les mois à
venir probablement à la mi avril après
les élections départementales
l'explication seulement 15 voix d'écart
un tract diffusé le vendredi soir
précédant le scrutin un appel sur
facebook lancée le samedi deuxième tour
ce qui est interdit
de quoi fausser les résultats voilà ce
que le conseil et a retenu pour motiver
l'annulation des élections à voisins le
bretonneux la mer alexandra rosetti
faisait part de sa déception sur le
plateau de télé fils ce jeudi soit moi
je suis assez triste de ce qui se passe
parce que ça donne une piètre image
effectivement de la classe politique est
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'autre chose
donc je suis triste pour ça je suis
triste et même même en colère parce que
je crois que lévis ynwa mérite mieux que
ça ils se sont prononcé il ya un an nous
avions un certain nombre de projets
engagés et ça peut bloquer tel type de
projet ah bah ça bloque des projets
d'aménagement en particulier mais ça
bloque aussi des projets de travaux
puisque plus personne ne pourra passer
d'appels d'offres une déception pour la
mary dei une satisfaction pour l'ump
alexis piette maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux 2,95 à mars 2014
il est celui qui a déposé les deux
recours devant le tribunal administratif
puis devant le conseil d'état
est ce que j'ai un sentiment de revanche
vous me demandez je ne le crois pas vous
savez je me suis consacré à cette
fonction de maire sans en faire une
carrière politique je n'ai jamais
vraiment voulu faire autre chose que
cela
mais ce n'est pas non plus ma profession
ça donne satisfaction aux vies si noir
parce que ils ont été trompés
c'est donc leur redonner la parole dans
des conditions qui cette fois ci je
l'espère seront égales pour tous et
respectueuse des lois
le préfet des yvelines doit maintenant
signifier à l'ensemble du conseil
municipal de voisins sa démission
il a ensuite huit jours pour nommer
délégation spéciale qui va prendre en
charge des affaires courantes de la
ville
les électeurs seront appelés aux urnes
probablement à la mi avril
l'opposition de gauche prépare sa liste
et fustige ce qu'elle appelle une guerre
d'ego pour moi c'est une guerre de deggo
une guerre de gens qui sont trop
intéressé par eux mêmes et pour eux
mêmes
c'est une cas qui n'a rien à voir sur
des valeurs rien à voir sur des
programmes et c'est au contraire une
guérilla tout à fait néfaste pour
voiteur alexandra rosetti a déclaré sur
notre plateau qu'elle sera bien
candidate et qu'elle mènera la même
liste qu'au dernières municipales quand
alexis biette ils disent offrir le temps
de la réflexion avant d'annoncer sa
candidature
décision prise la semaine prochaine à ce
sujet santé pour continuer l'association
yvelinoise france parkinson tenait une
réunion d'information l'occasion de
présenter le nouveau responsable local
jean yves à mathieu est aussi d'insister
sur les moyens
de prévention de la maladie j'en arrive
à me tuer le nouveau responsable yves
binois de france parkinson rien ne
transparaît et pourtant à 61 ans il est
atteint depuis 9 mois de la maladie est
une pathologie qu'ont eu son père et sa
mère ma fille cartonniste m'a dit un
jour en début 2015
oui j'en ligne pas pardon tu as tu
ressemble de plus en plus à papy donc tu
es un peu voûté tu traîne les pieds tu
allais les les bras qui ne bouge pas
quand tu marches et autres tu devrais
consulter
il faut se prépare à se préparer à une
diminution de ses capacités physiques
entre autres et donc il faut faire des
choses moi je vais deux fois par semaine
ou celle qui n'est je vais à la piscine
je fais de la marche est haute à dire
qu'on se prépare pour le futur c'est il
faut faire dès le départ vous faire
quand on est encore capable de le faire
la maladie de parkinson et génétique
dans 15% des cas dans les yvelines 3500
personnes en sont atteintes et 350
nouveaux cas détectés chaque année les
premiers 6 et les riders si les douleur
la raideur dans certaines choses les
bras qui ne balance pas quand on marche
la perte de l'odorat aussi des choses
qui sont considérés comme bénigne temps
normal mais qui peuvent des bons signes
indicateurs cette maladie dite du
mouvement est mal connue pour
l'association il manque de
professionnels de santé correctement
formés le besoin en clair des malades
c'est d'avoir une prise en charge liée
notamment à cette pathologie du
mouvement à ces mouvements qui sont
entravés qui sont gênés et cela veut
dire des compétences loeb bien sûr
neurologiques mais aussi des professions
paramédicales adapter la pathologiste
qui n'est aujourd'hui malheureusement
pas le cas c'est attirer l'attention des
pouvoirs publics sur ces besoins qui
sont prégnants qui sont extrêmement
importants pour lesquels les malades se
trouve ce que l'on appelle parfois en
errance médicale
la journée mondiale de la maladie de
parkinson a lieu le 9 avril ce sera
l'occasion pour demander plus de moyens
et mieux faire connaître la maladie en
france 150 mille personnes sont
atteintes et on poursuit cette édition
avec les sujets de la semaine écoulée
ce mardi on apprenait qu'une femme de 32
ans habitant guyancourt aurait rejoint
la syrie via la turquie avec son fils de
quatre ans pour faire le jihad
elle était employée à la mairie de
montigny le bretonneux et venait de
donner sa démission il y à un mois
c'est l'incompréhension qui règne car
cette animatrice de quartier n'avait
jamais montré aucun signe de
radicalisation c'est l'étonnement et
l'incompréhension qui règne en mairie de
montigny ce mercredi quand les agents
des couches chez nos confrères du
parisien
un article signalant qu'une animatrice
de la maison de quartier andré malraux
situé dans le quartier des prés seraient
partis faire le djihad en syrie la jeune
femme de 32 ans était employé en qualité
d'animatrice famille elle avait donné sa
démission et quitter son poste jeudi
dernier c'est samedi qu'elle aurait
rejoint la turquie avec son fils de
quatre ans en mairie on précise que
l'équipe de la maison de quartier a été
abasourdi par la nouvelle
elle ne montrait aucun signe de
radicalisation dit dans ses propos qui
était cohérente dans ses vêtements
la semaine dernière elle a encore
assisté à une réunion d'équipé et tout
s'est très bien passé explique-t-on en
mairie la municipalité précise
travailler de concert avec l'association
dire afin de mener un travail de
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes de la
ville
la mairie a aussi demandé à
l'association des musulmans de matinée
de faire preuve de vigilance
du côté de la mairie de guyancourt où
résidait cette jeune femme et sa famille
aucun commentaire à apporter
la mairie dit avoir découvert la sphère
dans les colonnes de nos confrères du
parisien
allez direction maintenant le salon de
l'agriculture vous le savez c'est
jusqu'au 1er mars le meilleur ouvrier de
france dans la classe fromager et
yvelinois c'est une distinction donc été
remise au salon de l'agriculture
heureusement seulement tous les quatre
ans florane parfait et william elles ont
suivi le concours pour nous pas une
minute à perdre pour ludovic bisous le
regard soucieux le fromager y concentrer
il est 7 heures du matin au salon de
l'agriculture les épreuves finales du
concours du
ouvrier de france classe fromager
commence ludovic s'est préparée 18 mois
pour ce grand jour
il a réussi plusieurs étapes pour
arriver jusqu'à l'épreuve du
chef-d'oeuvre 3h15 pour réaliser un
plateau remarquable avec plus de 50
fromage sous les yeux attentifs des
jurés thème de cette année
retour vers le futur
que certains vont peut-être aborder le
côté cinématographique avec la trilogie
mais nous on n'a pas vu ça on a vu
simplement retour vers le futur
savoir d'où l'on vient pour savoir où
l'on va donc la tradition chez nous ça
fait plus ici n'est encore fabrique du
fromage en france et puis eh bien il ya
le quotidien du crémier qui essaye
d'innover en permanence et ça c'est le
futur
au fil de l'épreuve les plateaux se
révèle plus spectaculaire le seigneur de
la compétition a eu comme les autres
candidats plusieurs mois pour réfléchir
au thème pour le décor il a pu compter
sur l'aide du musée rambolitains de
rambouillet je voulais faire un petit
train électrique et je voulais faire
passer un frein dans un tunnel creusé
dans un fromage c'est que la base du
concept qui avait un sens parce que
c'est le tramelot 19e siècle qui a
permis au fromage d'arriver dans les
villes avant dans l'évier non consommer
que des fromages de sa région où
l'horloge tourne
en plus du décor il faut disposer les
fromages soigneusement coupé à une heure
de la fin de l'épreuve ludovic se blesse
et la pression monte
le concours est enrayée france est
vraiment laid les gestes et les le
travail qu'on fait un peu tous les jours
chacun dans nos boutiques dans nos caves
dans la sélection des produits donc qui
a rien qui change vraiment sauf qu'on a
le stress parce que
vous êtes là il ya le public dans le
public sa famille et ses proches n'a
ludovic ne doit pas leur parler
il reste concentré et déjà l'épreuve
s'achève
dernière épreuve la technique de coupe
mais crise créativité les finalistes
sont aussi jugés sur la précision de
leurs gestes
plusieurs candidats peuvent être
consacrés meilleur ouvrier de france
mais il arrive parfois que personne ne
gagne le titre ça reste un concours donc
il peut y avoir de très bons
professionnels sans colle blanche midi
le concours se termine
ludovic rejoint son fan-club le fromager
est épuisé mais soulagé
pour moi c'était l'épreuve la plus
difficile c'est l'épreuve qui comptent
le plus dans la note globale
c'est l'épreuve la plus dure certains de
mes confrères redoutent l oral parce
qu'il ya on a eu un oral devant un grand
jury
moi j'avais moins peur de lowrie parce
que je confiance dans la capacité à
exprimer
je savais que j'étais un peu trop
ambitieux en termes de temps le jury
composé de meilleurs ouvriers de france
va maintenant examiner les
chefs-d'oeuvre la délibération va durer
plus de quatre heures il ne reste plus
qu'à attendre les résultats annoncés
dans la soirée
le lendemain nous retrouvons ludovic il
est de retour dans sa fromagerie à
rambouillet bonjour bienvenue
le fromager porte fièrement son col bleu
blanc rouge
le jury lui a décerné le titre de
meilleur ouvrier de france
ils ne sont que deux à avoir été
consacré cette année je savais aussi que
si mon nom sortait pas en premier et en
parts d'alphabétiser t'es foutu et mon
nom est sorti les 2010 hors employés
après après émotions fierté ses amis et
clients je vous embrasse super hier ils
ont suivi la compétition sur internet
aujourd'hui ses clients viennent pour le
féliciter
je suis je quelque part je suis un peu
fier pour lui quoi tout le travail qu'il
ya du gaz du fer franchement faut pas
dire autre chose que je suis vraiment
fier pour lui pour le concours ludovic
s'est imposé un rythme de vie stricte
coucher à 10 heures lever à 4 heures du
matin pendant un an pour s'entraîner un
investissement également financier
quinze mille euros sont à prévoir pour
pallier les frais du concours tout cela
est maintenant derrière lui
ludovic commencent à prendre conscience
de sa nouvelle vie ce qui va changer va
déjà je pense qu'il y aura un petit
appel un petit appel d'air au niveau de
la demande ça va attirer plus de clients
donc
il y faire face ceci dit moi j'ai pas de
grosses ambitions de développement je
rêve pas d'ouvrir un réseau de points de
vente
il y a 6 ans ludovic travailler en
costume derrière un bureau
aujourd'hui le nouveau meilleur ouvrier
de france et l'ambassadeur de sa
profession et cela pour la vie c'est ce
qu'on appelle une reconversion réussie
ah oui c'est peu de le dire bravo encore
à ce rambo lite
cette édition est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi le journal
revient en direct lundi à 18 heures nous
recevrons othman menace roux le
président de propofol qui viendra faire
un point sur la situation de la
pépinière d'entreprises je vous souhaite
un excellent week-end